-The NHL playoffs are under way,
so I thought it'd be a good time
for everyone to brush up
on who all the key players are.
-Oh, okay.
-It's time for "Fast Stats."
-♪ Learn some Fast Stats,
Fast Stats ♪
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-That ended like three times.
-♪ Learn some Fast Stats,
Fast Stats ♪
♪♪
-First, we have Cole Caufield.
Position -- right wing
for the Montreal Canadiens.
Catchphrase -- "Just wait
till my dad hears about this."
Also known for playing the bully
on every Disney Channel show.
[ Applause ]
Next, we have Jon Merrill.
Position -- defenseman
for the Montreal Canadiens.
Current hairstyle --
"Party in the back,
hangover in the front."
[ Laughter ]
How many times
he's wrecked a Jet Ski
through the side
of an AutoZone -- twice.
[ Applause ]
Jet Ski.
-Wow. Twice.
-He landed a Jet Ski
through the AutoZone.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Next up is Alex Newhook.
Position -- center
for the Colorado Avalanche.
Signature scent --
Proactiv solution.
Spends the off-season -- sitting
on a ventriloquist's lap.
-Great joke, Jimmy.
[ Laughing nasally ]
-Then we have Victor Hedman.
Position -- defenseman
for the Tampa Bay Lightning.
Hidden talent --
frying eggs with his mind.
[ Laughter ]
Medical condition --
resting mugshot face.
Yeah, there you go.
[ Applause ]
-[ Imitates oil hissing ]
-Next, we have J.T. Compher.
Position -- center
for the Colorado Avalanche.
Dyes his hair with --
Just for Men Stepchild.
[ Laughter ]
Sweats -- butterscotch.
[ Applause ]
Then we have Jordie Benn.
Position -- defenseman
for the Winnipeg Jets.
Family recipe --
roadkill cheesesteak.
Special talent -- can burp
and fart at the same time.
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-And finally,
it's Logan O'Connor.
Position -- right wing
for the Colorado Avalanche.
Favorite joke --
saying, "got your nose,"
but actually
ripping your nose off.
Nickname -- Five Loco.
This has been "Fast Stats."